معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
هشام جديد الوضع لديك في قطاع
غزه الجديد هو عمليات التمشيط التي مازالت
مستمره من قبل طواقم الدفاع المدني و من
قبل ايضا طواقم الاسعاف وحتى من المواطنين
حيث كانت منطقه صلاح الدين والمدخل على
صلاح الدين مدخل مخيم المغازي محظورا على
دخول المواطنين الفلسطينيين بفعل استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي واستمرار اطلاق النار
على المواطنين الذين يقتربون من تلك
المناطق قبل قليل وصل عدد من الشهداء
وايضا حتى تم انتشال واجلاء بعض الشهداء
واجلاء بعض المصابين من مخيم المغازي من
جراء استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي واستمرار
عمليات اطلاق النار عمليات التمشيط تتم في
كل صباح لكن بعض المناطق كان ممنوع من
الوصول اليها في ظل استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي لاسما مخيم المغازي حيث اطلقت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي النار على
المواطنين بالامس بكثافه استمر اطلاق
القذائف من قبل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه والدبابات الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه في عده محاور في مخيم المغازي
واطلقت هذه القذائف على منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين بعض من هؤلاء المواطنين
استشهد في الشارع وظل ملقى على الارض في
الشارع منذ امس وتم اجلاء وانتشال بعض
المصابين وايضا انتشال بعض الجثامين صباح
هذا اليوم القصف الاسرائيلي مازال مستمرا
ونستمع الان الى اصوات من هذه القذائف
التي تطلقها الدبابات الاسرائيليه في شرق
دير البلح حيث تستمر هذه الدبابات باطلاق
هذه القذائف على مناطق مختلفه كما يسمع ما
بين الفينه والاخرى اصوات اطلاق نار من
قبل هذه الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من
رشاشات ثقيله تطلق النار على منازل
المواطنين نحن نستمع الان الى اصوات هذه
النيران المطلقه من قبل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه تدور ما
بين الفينه والاخرى ما بين على ما يبدو
عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مخيم
المغازي في شرق دير البلح ايضا في مخيم
البريج الذي ما زال محظورا على السكان
الدخول او حتى الخروج من مخيم البريج
العمليه في مخيم البريج ما تزال مستمره
الدبابات الاسرائيليه متواجده في عده
مناطق في مخيم البريج وتطلق النار
والقذائف على المواطنين الفلسطينيين وجل
الاستهدافات من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه او حتى من الدبابات العسكريه
المتواجده والمتوج داخل المخيم هي على
منازل المواطنين وبالتالي هنا هناك عداد
من الشهداء والجرحى يوميا هناك نقل
لاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وايضا
اجلاء وانتشال لعدد من الجثامين من جراء
استمرار هذا القصف الاسرائيلي ربما
المنطقه الوسطى باتت تشهد الكثافه الناريه
الاعلى في قطاع غزه وايضا الغارات الاعنف
لا سما مع بدء الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليته
البريه منطلقا من مخيم البريج والان الان
نستمع الى اصوات انفجارات ناجمه على ما
يبد عن استمرار لهذا القصف الاسرائيلي من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وقد نفذت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا غارات منذ صباح
وفجر هذا اليوم على عده مناطق منطقه
الزوايده شهدت غارات عنيفه على هذه
المنطقه وكانت في اراضي الزراعيه وبعض
البنى التحتيه والشوارع ايضا مخيم المغازي
مخيم البريج وكذلك مخيم النصيرات الذي بات
يشهد ايضا قصفا عنيفا من المدفعيه لا سما
الجهه الشماليه لهذا المخيم ايضا منطقه
المغرا ومنطقه مدينه الزهراء وكلهم
يتعرضون الى قصف مدفعي وما بين الفينه
والاخرى هناك غارات عنيفه من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه لكن حتى معرفه طبيعه
هذه الغارات بات صعبا بل يكاد يكون مستحيل
في ظل استمرار القصف ومنع حتى الطواقم
الصحفيه والطواقم الطبيه وطواقم الدفاع
المدني من الوصول الى الاماكن التي
تستهدفها هذه الطائرات وبالتالي من يصاب
من يدمر منزله يبقى تحت الانقاض حتى تعود
وتتراجع الدبابات الاسرائ ويتوقف اطلاق
النار وربما هذا يستمر لايام واسابيع من
اجل انتشال هذه الجثامين من هذه من
الشوارع ومن المنازل التي يتم استهدافها
نستمع الان الى اصوات اشتباكات على ما
يبدو انها في المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح
وسط القطاع لكن المنطقه الوسطى وفي ظل ما
تشهده من كثافه ناريه ايضا القصف مستمر في
خانيونس في رفح وكل هذه المناطق في
خانيونس المناطق الشرقيه لخاني وس تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هذه المناطق بن السيلا وخزاعه
والقرار وعبس ما زالت محاصره وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تمنع سيارات الاسعاف
والطواقم كذلك من الدخول الى هذه المناطق
منطقه وسط البلد في خانيونس ايضا تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه كذلك وهناك
غارات نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على عده منازل في تلك المنطقه
في رفح المكان ربما الاكثر اكتظاظا في
قطاع غزه وبات بحسب بلديه بلديه رفح هناك
1300 فلسطيني يتواجدون في مدينه رفح ورغم
كل ذلك القصف الاسرائيلي مستمر ومتواصل
وقصفت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه فجر
هذا اليوم منزلا وهناك ست شهداء فيما لا
يزال ايضا هناك العشرات من المفقودين تحت
المنزل الذي استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه دمرته وسوته بالارض وهناك
عشرات من المفقودين ما زالوا تحته من بين
هؤلاء بالتاكيد نازحون هربوا من القصف
الاسرائيلي في مناطق مختلفه ولجوا الى
مدينه رفح بعدما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
للسكان ان توجهوا الى رفح وتوجهوا الى دير
البلح ورغم كل ذلك يقصف هذا هاتين
المدينتين بعنف الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تنفذ ما بين الفينه والاخرى
غارات على هاتين المدينتين وبالتالي هناك
شهداء وجرحى ينقلون يوميا من هذا من هاتين
المدينتين ايضا مدينه غزه رغم انسحاب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من عده مناطق ومن عده
احياء في مدينه غزه الا ان القصف
الاسرائيلي مازال مستمرا عليها غارات جويه
عنيفه تنفذها الطائرات الحربيه الاسرا
على مدار اللحظه في كل منطقه بعينها في
مدينه غزه هناك على الاقل اكثر من 30
شهيدا سقطوا بالامس من جراء استمرار هذه
الغارات على مدينه غزه كذلك شمال القطاع
ايضا هناك غارات عنيفه من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ما بين فينه واخرى
شكرا لك هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح